[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Aurélie makadou
directrice adjointe du sac à HR et
responsable de la programmation jeune
public bonjour bonjour Alors du premier
au 20 avril le sac s'organise le
festival les pépites sonores un festival
musical pour enfants cette année c'est
la dixième édition quelle est l'histoire
de ce festival alors ce festival est né
donc en 2013
c'était mon collègue Frédéric Lamandé
qui s'occupait de la programmation et
qui est aujourd'hui programmateur en
musique actuelle et à l'époque c'était
avec Victory music en fait qu'on était
associé voilà sur la programmation et
parce qu'il y a toujours eu voilà dans
l'émission du sax de programmer pour le
jeune public et tout ça toujours été un
espace musical donc voilà naturellement
en fait de de voilà de regarder ce qui
ce qui avait de près en tout cas en
musique pour le jeune public et de se
rendre compte qu'il y avait déjà une
belle proposition
en termes de spectacle pour les pour les
enfants car justement vous en tant que
responsable du coût de la programmation
jeune public quelles sont vos ambitions
en termes de de culture pour les enfants
alors c'est vrai que dans ce festival ce
qui nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
évidemment de proposer des formes
importantes en musique et de pas de pas
avoir d'efforts au rabais je dirais de
spectacle parce que c'est des enfants
mais au contraire il faut il faut leur
montrer toute la richesse et surtout en
musique il y a vraiment une palette de
de proposition assez riche donc
avec des grandes formes ce qu'on appelle
des grandes formes donc souvent des
spectacles avec une dizaine de musiciens
ou plus voilà ça ça nous a toujours
importé de faire ce genre de proposition
aussi d'avoir un travail un peu sur la
la transmission et de de pouvoir comme
ça accueillir aussi les parents les
grands-parents donc à toujours avec une
figure par exemple de la chanson
française voilà on a déjà fait des des
spectacles autour de Gainsbourg avec
Gainsbourg for ou autour de Joe Dassin
voilà donc ça et puis évidemment de
d'accompagner la création de balayer un
peu toutes les disciplines toutes les
propositions en tout cas en musique que
ce soit électro jazz rock voilà et puis
les différentes formes aussi de pouvoirs
s'ouvrir dans différents lieux voilà
alors justement au programme un
spectacle musical danse concert électro
mandingue ou Franco suédois jazz rock ou
encore blues les spectacles sont
disponibles pour la plupart à partir de
5 ou 6 ans d'autres à partir de 2 ans
alors quel est qu'importe pardon l'art
du spectacle et la musique à nos enfants
selon vous
[Musique]
de peut-être aussi d'y associer parfois
de la pratique on a aussi des ateliers
on en reparlera plus tard peut-être mais
on a aussi des ateliers
voilà les éveiller alors c'est vrai que
là par exemple il y a un petit
féconducteur sur cette édition autour
des langues vous citiez des exemples de
Franco suédois etc donc il y a aussi des
spectacles cette année que je trouvais
intéressant ou voilà vous pouvez faire
entendre plusieurs langues et donc la
richesse ça c'est important avec voilà
avec le covid et aussi le fait d'avoir
été enfermé de pas pu voyager pendant un
moment là c'était c'était important
aussi de le faire découvrir ça spectacle
son programme à la fois au sax mais
également dans les communes voisines de
de HR pourquoi proposer des spectacles
hors les murs et comment la
collaboration entre entre les communes
avec les autres communes ce sont enfin
ont été rendues possibles alors ça ça
s'est fait progressivement ça a commencé
en 2017
à Andrésy et puis progressivement à
Poissy ensuite nous a rejoint
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine donc avec le
storyboat voilà donc il y a des lieux
aussi très très divers il y a la maison
des insectes à Carrières-sous-Poissy la
médiathèque Christine de Pisan à Poissy
aussi
et bien dans l'axe l'idée c'était de la
collaboration pardon elle se fait avec
les responsables de chaque lieu donc ça
peut être les villes où les ou les
structures indépendantes et donc moi
avoir fait des propositions de spectacle
parfois qu'on peut aller voir ensemble
et voilà en fait alors après il faut que
ça soit en lien avec le lieu par exemple
la maison des insectes on essaye de
trouver des propositions en lien avec la
thématique avec la nature avec les
insectes on va faire un petit tour
justement d'horizon des spectacles pour
pour ce festival les pépites sonores le
2 avril c'est un concert à danser que
vous proposez à partir de 5 ans alors
qu'est-ce que ça signifie et pourquoi
c'est un spectacle à ne pas louper alors
c'est tascabilissimo et donc c'est
vraiment un concert à pas louper parce
qu'on va entendre la de l'italien des
tarentelles donc ce sont deux
musiciennes une violoniste et une
accordéoniste une qui va chanter aussi
en cajun c'est un peu un voyage et voilà
c'est très c'est très frais elles sont
très drôles c'est à partir de 4,5 ans et
l'idée voilà c'est de d'écouter de la
musique en même temps d'avoir envie de
se lever de son siège et d'aller danser
le 8 avril c'est un concert Franco
suédois ça s'appelle comme c'est étrange
de quoi va-t-on parler lors de ce
spectacle alors de donc c'est un
spectacle voilà qui parle aussi un petit
peu des petites peurs qu'on peut avoir
et en même temps il y a beaucoup de
fantaisies beaucoup de poésies il y a
une chanson sur les trolls qui fait un
petit peu peur et en même temps on
revient après avec une berceuse voilà et
on entend évidemment du Sud et aussi du
français les enfants sont pas du tout
perdus même si on entend du suédoise ils
vont découvrir et aussi pas mal
d'instruments elle joue pareil de
l'accordéon des percussions
voilà c'est tout pour se faire une idée
plus précise on va écouter justement un
extrait du spectacle et on poursuit
juste après
j'aime j'aime
j'aime
j'aime j'aime j'aime j'aime
les cafards en purée les crapauds
engelés
[Musique]
la particularité de ce spectacle alors
c'est un spectacle qui mêle
théâtre d'ombre et chanson et donc c'est
l'artiste boule qu'on a déjà accueilli
alors pas du tout sur des propositions
jeunes publiques et là ce qui était
touchant c'est que c'est son premier
jeune public et c'est sur l'histoire de
Brassens et donc c'est cette c'est cet
artiste qui a nourri cette boule en fait
qui lui a donné envie ensuite de jouer
de la musique et donc de composer et
donc c'est ses compositions à cet
artiste vraiment à la guitare mais qui
raconte l'histoire de deux Brassens de
son enfance à 7 jusqu'à l'artiste qu'on
a connu ensuite et toute la progression
donc c'est aussi il y a plein de valeurs
en fait plein de plein de messages aussi
pour les enfants de
ben voilà de de
de déjà il y a la découverte d'un
artiste parce que cet artiste là a
traversé plusieurs générations et il va
de toute façon en traverser en traverser
une autre on a parlé également du voyage
tout à l'heure de la découverte c'est un
petit peu vos valeurs justement dans ce
festival d'avoir des enfants face à vous
face à un spectacle qui ont découvert
qui vont voyager qui vont même au niveau
des langues etc oui absolument au niveau
des langues ça me ça me paraît important
et puis même au niveau de la musique on
parlait des styles tout à l'heure la
découverte le voyage la musique c'est
aussi voyager on n'a pas parlé dans
notre spectacle autour du blues qui
s'appelle les bedaines de coton mais il
y a ça aussi voilà ça peut être voilà de
vraiment
les bedaines de coton c'est le mercredi
5 avril ce sera à Chanteloup et ce sera
au Phénix une nouvelle salle en fait
voilà qui vous en ayez parlé comme ça on
le note aussi dans dans l'agenda le 16
avril c'est un concert électro mandingue
accessible dès 6 mois donc je parlais de
deux ans minimum mais non c'est c'est
même six mois ce spectacle est ouvert
donc au plus petit qu'est-ce que
l'électro mandingue et qu'est-ce qui
attend le jeune public alors là c'est un
spectacle très doux tout en douceur qui
s'appelle une journée attaque du goût et
qui et qui raconte en fait une journée
le quotidien en fait dans un dans un
village au Burkina Faso et donc on
entend on entend la langue voilà pareil
et des donc elle a il y a la musique
traditionnelle et très douce de la cora
et qui se confronte en fait avec des
nappes
électro
voilà donc c'est ce contraste qui est
intéressant et qui du coup je pense et
super aussi pour des adultes voilà moi
j'ai vu des adultes
les adultes participent de toute façon
au spectacle donc c'est ouvert aux
jeunes publics mais les adultes
participent au spectacle et peuvent
venir de toute façon avec leurs enfants
et oui surtout ils viennent oui c'est
important parce que c'est pas que pour
les enfants c'est surtout ça et c'est
toujours difficile quand on parle de
tranche d'âge parce qu'en fait voilà ça
va au-delà évidemment de ce qu'on peut
imaginer et à tout âge ça fonctionne et
ça et ça nous ramène soit à notre part
d'enfance soit voilà ça nous ça nous
transporte ça nous fait voyager il nous
fait découvrir d'autres choses et donc
du coup on n'a pas parlé aussi de
Dracula qui est quand même le spectacle
qui va ouvrir ce festival le premier
avril avec le l'Orchestre National de
Jazz c'est son premier jeune public avec
11 musiciens voilà donc ça va être aussi
un bon moment et on vous proposerait
également des ateliers parents
parents-enfants en deux trois mots
quelles sont ses ateliers justement par
enfant alors justement là on en a
proposé un en amont Dracula donc ce sera
le mercredi 29 mars c'est un
goûter filo voilà sur les thèmes qui
traversent Dracula le spectacle donc
l'amour la mort donc voilà avec le
personnage de Dracula qu'on retrouvera
dans dans ce spectacle et puis et puis
quelqu'un qui est spécialisé aussi en
philo et qui fera parler les enfants et
les parents l'idée c'est de voilà qui
est un temps de partage entre les
adultes et les enfants pour ensuite les
emmener au spectacle qui rencontrent en
fait en amont les artistes et qui est
une pratique donc là ça va être plutôt
sous forme de de discussion mais on a
aussi des ateliers d'initiation à la
musique électronique en lien avec une
journée attaquer les Dougou voilà pour
les trois ans et 6 ans et qui auront une
approche de la musique électro et toute
la programmation est à retrouver donc
sur votre sur votre site le sax tiré HR
78.fr merci beaucoup Aurélie makadou
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]